okay so if you read question 18 I think
part of what makes it tricky is that
it's just one long sentence and it's not
hard to even understand what it's
getting at let alone how to solve it
okay so let's try to break it apart and
see how we can approaches okay so show
that if the first second and fourth
terms of an AP now stop there it's all
be in general that's part of what's
tricky about this it doesn't say you
know the terms are this that and the
other it's just saying there is an AP
and it's I'm looking at these particular
terms so since it's all general let's
try to set up what we can the AP any AP
in general will have the form first term
in a second term being a plus whatever
difference there is right and I don't
know anything else apart from that like
there's no extra information I'm being
given to it since the first term there's
a second term the third term will be to
not say the difference so that's not a
plus and the fourth term we through the
slit okay now I could keep on doing more
terms but these are the ones that were
interested in it says the first second
and fourth first second and fourth terms
okay now this say that these three form
a geometric sequence now let's think
what's the definition of a geometric
sequence how do you prove that a
sequences geometric form or not I'm
gonna say by the way as you as you do
you're working for this question
and this would be a pretty good example
you want to actually explain you the
logic between your one so I'm gonna
write down a fraction here to set
because that's what gp's are about
ratios but before I do that what explain
why right so I'm gonna say
1:10 - and former GP okay so that's
that's the logical kidding now therefore
the thing about a GPS in the common
ratio right so if I take this term in
this term it don't write them a Westie
hey that should be equal to the ratio of
the next two terms as well namely those
two all right now if that's the case
that's what we know okay sure that
either the sequence is one a clustered
sequence or two the terms are the
positive integer multiples on the first
turn okay now before we start working
this and trying to get towards a
solution we need to understand what
those two things mean okay so I'll just
come over here
what would a constant sequence they
haven't defined the term for us normally
an arithmetic progression series
whatever all the terms will be constant
right so I don't think maybe the terms
themselves are constant I think it means
that the whole sequence is constant all
the terms are the same right so if all
the terms here were the same you know
like this what does that mean about the
NP it would mean that the difference is
equal to zero okay so if we can ensure
this that this is the case then we'll
approve the first part if the sequence
we've got is a constant C then the next
thing it says is the terms of this
sequence are the positive integer
multiples of the first the terms
positive integer multiples all and the
first term is just a okay now if that
were the case that would mean the first
term is pay
what would the second term be if it's
going to be a common sorry a positive
integer multiple of this I guess I've
been to the next B yes these are the
multiples of anything okay now I can
rewrite this in terms of what I've
already said about the sequence right
maybe this is pay this is going to be a
plus the common difference if it's to a
then a plus the commodores the
conditions woopi-hey that okay that's
the D I'm after and then in the same way
this third term will be a plus - lots of
the common difference which again is
going to be a okay so the words in this
case the common difference is the first
so now that I understand I've sort of
translated right I want to prove that
either this is the case or this is the
case sort of what I'm going for and
they're saying it's one or the other
all right now there's my endpoint that's
what I'm required to prove
so let's come back to actually what we
know right well what can we do with this
thing I guess I want to simplify and
solve for D right that's what both of
these conditions are about so I guess
what could do here would you cross
multiply this a fairly traditional
strategy one fractions like that okay we
can expand this okay remember now that
I've got everything expanded out what am
I trying to get a mustard seed right and
I'm looking at it this is a good sign
that we're in the right direction
because he's a Squared's okay so with
each other
on this to ad and this three ad we can
bridge each other so I might write bring
that three ad over to the other side
subtract three from both sides so that I
can meet these squared minus is equal to
zero
is that okay okay now at this point I
could divide by D right that would that
would make things simpler but you can
see number one is a bad idea because I'm
going to lose a solution number two I
actually know already I can't do that
because I'm after this right if d0z I
can't divide by now right so it's gonna
be a problem
so still just factorize okay okay so you
can see that's as far as I need to go
now the immediate next line is these two
because I'm just solving for D all right
D is equal to look at it it's not all
that hard right how many lines have
working do we have one two three four
five six so it's not a difficult
question where is the difficulty it's in
terms of starting off with something
they don't give you the terms you've got
to work them out yourself you've got to
set this kind of thing up and interpret
properly and then know what these two
would actually mean if you were trying
to prove them is that okay
so I go that make sense of that question
and papi follows in a very similar style